we do have a real crisis in education in
the developing world in in Africa and
Asia we still have so many children out
of school often the quicker figure that
sighted is around 140 million children
some people are saying as high as 250
million children who do not have access
to a school place
there's also question what do we do once
those children are in school because
many of them are in a class where the
teacher is not qualified or indeed where
the teacher is completely absent from
that class in the developed world the
issue is equally strong because we're
spending 12 years of a child's education
and they are leaving school and they
don't have the skills that employers and
society say that they need them to have
we have mass youth unemployment we have
a lot of graduate unemployment and at
the same time we have a real gap between
the skills that are required and what it
is that those young people are able to
do I think it's really important that we
look at the data we look at the evidence
of what works when we're looking at how
do you make every school a great school
for example here in gems education
solutions we've developed a methodology
for supporting schools in improvement
and at the heart of that is an
understanding of how you make a school
better
first of all it's about educational
excellence we need to look at the
quality of leadership quality of
teaching the curriculum very importantly
how it teachers empowered to plan assess
develop their practice and be the lead
people for taking the profession
forwards and by doing that we find that
standards can rise much more quickly but
equally important how do we engage the
parents this is a key part of
educational effectiveness we know that
children with engaged parents improving
their educational quality much more
quickly than those with parents who are
disengaged in education the other side
of the coin to educational effectiveness
is operational effectiveness and this is
something that we in education have only
recently become
to become much better at this is about
how do we efficiently deploy the
resources that we have it's also about
how do we introduce the right processes
in our schools and businesses will look
in detail at their processes what is it
that we do from top to bottom to deliver
the right result in schools often it can
be more intuitive
however by analyzing the key processes
in a school and actually making sure
that each of them is being delivered in
the most efficient way by the right
people using the right technology we can
actually help to use our money better
and this is the point around financial
effectiveness because if we are
delivering high quality education and
we're doing it in a way which is
operationally effective then we're
making the best use of our resources
it's also very important to make sure
that all of the stakeholders are really
engaged in the work you're doing so what
is it that the parents think what are
the teachers think what do the students
think how does that all come together to
make sure that we have a school that is
going to continue to improve be critical
of itself and do the very best it can
for its community